[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity a state and local governments
attempt to mitigate the spread of kovat
19 some are now being accused of
trampling on the constitutional rights
of American citizens for example in
Houston a new mandate would find
residents of thousand bucks just for not
wearing a mask in public
Houston's police union president is
calling the measure draconian others are
protesting the mandate which is now
facing a court challenge and in Michigan
state lawmakers attempting to restrain
the governor's emergency powers after
she issued widespread bans at one point
even prohibiting members of the same
family from visiting each other
my guess is there are some families who
would actually approve of that but not
many governor Gretchen Whitmer today
announced that she was going to ease
some of the stay at home orders but the
governor continues to face a wave of
criticism and in Washington state that
state one vote away from releasing some
of its most dangerous inmates all to
fight the spread of kovat 19 in a 5 to 4
decision the state Supreme Court denied
the release of these convicts including
potentially the Green River Killer
joining us now with more fox news
contributor trey gowdy
Trey you were in Congress long enough to
not like it very well you're back home
in South Carolina but what we're seeing
all across the country is some very
heavy-handed policies being passed out
at the local level by governors and
county commissions and mayors is this a
threat to the long term life and liberty
of the United States and its people well
first of all governor is great great to
be with you yeah there has to be a
rationality anytime government asks the
citizenry to do something there has to
be a rational basis for it and the
greater the freedom you infringe the
more compelling the reason has to be so
if I'm going to imprison you or find you
for not wearing a mask why can't I hold
you down and vaccinate you against the
flu this fall I mean you don't want the
flu and covet 19 so can i involuntarily
vaccinate you can I show up at your
house and make sure you're doing your
burpees and your planks and your jumping
jacks because obesity and kovat 19 don't
go well together where does it stop and
in Houston governor if you can believe
this they're threatening to punish
people for not wearing a mask meanwhile
at Washington State they're gonna let a
serial killer there one vote away from
letting a serial killer out because of
kovat 19 so you go to jail for not
wearing a mass but if you kill four
dozen women because the koban 19 we
might let you out that is irrational
you're in the Justice Department as a
federal prosecutor prior to go into
Congress so you understand the Justice
Department you also understand the power
of the federal government and what they
can do the federal government can also
defend civil liberties if they want to
and right now Attorney General Bill Barr
seems to be indicating that he's willing
to stand up for citizens to make sure
that constitutional rights don't get
trampled on what do you think is gonna
happen out of that well I think we're
really lucky we have a real lawyer as
the AG I mean he is a real lawyer so he
understands that for government to be
able to enjoy a freedom or infringe on
the freedom there has to be a rational
basis and sometimes a compelling reason
so well I'm going to tell you governor
that you can't go visit your mom um
that's a fundamental right that you have
so the reason that I'm the reason I
offer to keep you from doing that has to
be incredibly compelling it has to be
more than just the governor of Michigan
thinks it's a good idea if I tell you
that you have to wear something in
public there has to be a rational basis
for that so Barr is smart enough to know
that and he'll put the power of the
federal government and grants for those
states and municipalities that don't
want to go along with the power of the
purse and the power to go to court
congressman Gowdy we've seen some pretty
crazy stuff like in Michigan the
governor says you can't mow your lawn
I'm having a hard time understanding how
mowing a lawn is going to make me more
subject to getting the Cova 19 virus
yeah it is the responsible you were the
governor of a great state Arkansas she's
the governor of a great state it is her
job to persuade her citizenry that what
she's telling them they
do is somehow rationally rooted in
public health so good luck convincing
anyone that mowing your front lawn is
going to make you more susceptible to
Cove at 19 look I get encouraging people
not to go see those that are vulnerable
but but asking me not to go see my mom
is very different from telling me that I
am forbidden on penalty of law from
going to see my mom and that's what has
the protesters and other I'm not a
protester but I want government to
explain to me if I'm gonna infringe on
your freedom it's for a compelling
reason Americans are sacrificial
governor you know that they're
sacrificial
but it's not too much to ask why are you
making me do that and is it rooted and
some rationality that is connected with
what we're trying to prevent and if it's
not then we have this thing called civil
disobedience and people can engage in it
and I think that's what we're seeing
congressman there are a lot of people
who are ready to engage in it they're
they're not unreasonable and I
appreciate your saying that because the
protesters aren't all just a bunch of
crazies these are people who
fundamentally know what their basic
rights are congressman trey Gowdy so
glad to have you here thank you for
joining us delighted to see you this one